we didn't had any intention of injecting
these type of vials to patient because
we needed a lot of vials to be able to
file a clinical trial application and
this was planned to be done with
University College London before any new
medication or therapy is considered safe
and effective it must first be
rigorously tested through clinical
trials
these trials are fundamental in
determining and experimental treatments
dosage and safety and to identify any
possible side effects at the University
College London Great Ormond Street
Institute of Child Health professor
Waseem Kassim was working with selected
as the principal investigator taking the
universal car t-cells from the lab to
trials normally this process can take
over a decade with nearly endless layers
of approval so our questions were what
do you do if your patient is already so
unwell that you can't Excel or is had so
much chemotherapy that there's no white
blood cells left to collect that you
think are going to be useful how do you
do this process in a way that can be
done quickly and delivered back to the
patient in a timely manner and the
answer that is perhaps being able to use
a product the cell product that's being
made beforehand that can be given back
to multiple patients now in order to do
that we have to overcome the barrier of
transplantation which means if I put my
cells into a non matched individual the
cells were still want to react against
that individual because they'll know the
individuals forum and secondly the
person receiving the cells will try and
reject them because they know the cells
are not their own in affiliation with
professor Kassim dr. Paul Vaes works on
the front line with patients who
desperately need new cancer treatment
options
I'll have treated well over 2,000
patients and at least 600 of those will
have gone wrong so there's a lot of
patience as we lose it's unsuccessful
and you've got to be able to come in the
next day
even from our failures we've learned
lots and if we hadn't gone through those
failures we wouldn't be having some of
the successes we have today that's
always been good did not have any bait
just infection let's warm it up sit
forward again perfect okay big breath
[Music]